hello everyone and welcome to the 2019
Tata Steel chess tournament this is the
final round as we mentioned yesterday
after round 12 Carson is an eight and a
half out of 12 and Geary's on eight out
of 12 so Geary is the only person other
than Carson who can win this tournament
but to win it he has to beat Carson it's
I don't know he couldn't ask for
anything more he has the white pieces in
the last round against the world
champion so that's I mean it's not
something you can force
there's no line that will allow you to
play like for the win more than another
line if your opponent isn't interested
in venturing into something exotic or
you know wants to win himself like if
Carson would pull a selector here we
might say it's a very hard forgive it
will be very hard for Geary to find any
winning chances but you know he really
wants to win this it's it's his home
country of Netherlands and he would very
much enjoy winning this tournament so
without further ado there are some of
the games still being played I'm
recording this as it has just finished
so let's see what happened here
Geary has the white pieces and he opens
with E for Carlsen goes c5 as this is
something he currently I believe is the
most prepared to do as he used it in
pretty much every game with the black
pieces against Fabiano Caruana
in the World Chess Championship match we
have Knight to f3 knight c6 and now d4
see capture snipe capture so we have
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now II
five kicking the knight back we have
Knight beat Knight d2 B 5 and now not
Knight d5 as we've already seen plenty
of times in the monsters championship
match but Bishop to g5 sorry first d6
and then Bishop to g5 and here we
entered the last pair of Pelican
variation and they are following the
game cost and already played with the
black pieces in this tournament in the
Tata Steel 2019 against team order a job
of a6 Carson continues in the same
fashion with 9 3 3 b5 Knight to d5
and now verse 37 Bishop captures the
Bishop captures and now c3 everything
the same as in that game and here we
have Bishop to g5 a played in the other
game across and plated castles here but
it doesn't matter as the game will once
again reach the same position from the
job of Carlsen game only through some of
the different move order rush up to g5
and Knight back to C to Ruby 8 and now
we have Bishop to e2 now we have castles
by Carlsen castles by giri and here
cousin spent some 20 minutes in this
position and he played the exact same
move he played against our job came to
h8 and we do have the exact same
position cousin had against our job of
after 14 moves one of the reasons why
Carlsen could have been spending 20
minutes on a move he already played in
this tournament against our job of even
though that game ended in a draw
perhaps he was contemplating f5 if it
was possible here as in in his interview
after the game with her job of he said
that to look for any kind of advantage
with the black pieces you don't want to
execute f5 at some point in this game
but it's he wasn't able to figure out
how to do it and here I don't think he
was thinking that Geary would go for the
same line or or or even allow him to
play this line of the Sicilian that he
knows so well so I don't
perhaps he prepared something else after
his game against or a job of but who
knows
so after castles we have King to h8 and
now comes Bishop to g4 and here we go
away from the game against a job of here
or a job of played a3 and the game
continued as it did but here we have
Bishop to g4 a new move by Geary but
it's still not a new game this move has
been played before but here we have g6
as an own move and Bishop to e6 sno move
after Carlson's move Bishop to b7 now we
have a completely new game on our hands
so it's Carson who first deviates from
the own theory
night c2b for offering offering a
trailer of nights here we have night
captures and here Gary can either
capture with the pawn or with the night
capturing good the night is very
interesting for example ignite captures
then Bishop can capture on e4 and after
we capture on a6 rook kicks back the
night tonight goes back and now Bishop
goes back to be seven black eliminates
White's efore pawn but in exchange white
gets rid of blacks a6 bone so here white
would have three to one advantage and
the Queen side but black would have a
very strong center Giri doesn't like
this instead he goes see captures he
opens up the C file and he says okay
perhaps this a six bone we will be a
long-term weakness and my eforp own is
very useful here we have G sense by
Carson preparing f5 in some lines as a
cross and already mentioned that if
black does not execute a5 he cannot look
for anything more than a win and it's
interesting Carson doesn't need a win
Qasim only needs a draw and he is the
winner of the status till 2019 but you
know if you play for a draw there are
sometimes greater chances you're going
to lose the game than if you play for a
win we have a four by Giri and now comes
B capture something for rook captures on
a4 and now comes a bishop to c6 by
crossing and here Gary really started
spending time because there is one line
that well everyone thought that gear was
going to go for as it's the line sister
recommended and everyone who listens to
say say this these days and that is
route captures on a6 eliminating the
spot and allowing this exchange
sacrifice and after Bishop to e2 Buster
captures Bishop captures and now you
would have this position were white
sacrifice the exchange but white species
are much more active and you do have
this pawn which could potentially be
very dangerous as well even now the the
bishop and Knight are controlling the
squares the the pawn can use the to be
pushed forward but again went for a
different line you went for Bishop to e2
a similar exchange sacrifice but it
gives black much more activity here
bunch of characters and a force plate
cousin captures the exchange we have
Queen captures on a four and now again
there is a very nice line by sis a that
is a five simply offering to trade this
or to push b5 but for example B captures
on a five row capture some b2 attacking
the bishop here and now after Bishop to
c4 again this could be a very dangerous
pawn but black on the other hand would
also be very active for example you have
a lot of pressure against this f2 pawn
you can push a five now break open the F
file and for example play Queen c7
twenty-five control the a7 square if the
pawn is to be pushed there and this rook
will also be controlling the a8 square
so you know it's it's a trade off but
cross someone for a different line
instead of this a5 move Karsten
immediately pushes f5 and okay we have
captures on f5 because if for example if
you play something like Queen captures
too quickly then F captures here and
then even III will be an idea so I like
we said each chapters on f5 we have rook
captures on f5 and now bush up the d3
attacking Carlson's rock on f5 and now
goes back to f8 and here we have Queen
captures on a6 so again we have a
similar position and now perhaps this
pawn can once again be very dangerous
but what do you play here if you play
something like group to f7 to get this
rook over to the B file to help out with
the defense it is possible for example
b5 row goes here and you know you hold
but cross and finds a more interesting
idea let's say he plays Bishop to d2 and
it's quite quite the move as it attacks
the b4 pawn twice in someone's it also
keeps the c3 square away from the White
Queen for example if the Queen's are
ever you know if there will ever be
attention with the Queen's along the C
file and then the White Queen can never
occupy the c3 squares so white will not
be able for example to under both his
pawns but also there's a very
interesting line if white starts pushing
immediately then black has this Bishop
to a5 move and then controlling these
squares are very nicely
and then for example root 2 a1 will not
be possible because of Roop to a8 and
now after Queen to be 7 Queen h4 wins
for black as there is now too much
pressure on the kingside you will have
to go back now comes Queen before you
attack the bishop here and now it's it's
simply a lost position for white now you
could try a trick Knight of 6 you
threaten checkmate or if black captures
you can capture the rook on a 8 but
black and defend with rook to a7 the
Queen is defending the rook here and now
after Queen to e4 you will simply
capture on f6 and black just lost a very
nice knight on f6 Wien captures pawn
captures and you are up a whole rook
so after this Bishop to DQ move Giri
goes for Queen to c4 instead and here
cousin can't react and to grab this
point immediately because of a tactic if
Bishop captures Knight captures and rook
to f4 hoping to win this night it
doesn't work because of Bishop to b4
white will just block and now there's no
way to force anything to happen here for
example if you push white doesn't have
to capture with the Queen or the bishop
but rather with the night and everything
is all right here the rook is under
attack you have to move and now the
b-pawn starts marching forward and now
it's just white who is much better and
the winning of course
so after this Queen to c4 across and has
the option of going rogue state or in
this case a queen to see it which cross
and played and now also I think we
mentioned now the Quintus III would be
an excellent square for whites Queen
where white would be able to under ball
his pawns
if black we decided to trade Queens but
also you would pressure the black King
very nicely along this dark square
diagonal f4 could be an idea in the
future but here such things are not
possible here a Giri goes for a pretty
forced line we have Queen to b4 now
Carson is able to capture this pawn
which he does with lots of character son
before Knight captures and only now rook
to f4
now the Queen has to move we have Queen
to c6 offering a trade here but of
course Crossing is not interested we
have rook F capture Sun before and now
Queen captures on b6 and now Carlson is
in a bit of a pickle we could say
because there's no
good way to defend this pawn and also
Queen to f6 check is coming and after
these threats b3 and Bishop to c4 is a
very strong idea
so here it's very hard to defend the
pawn for example if cross and goes Queen
e8 defends the pawn and you really want
to defend the point if you're ever to
hope to have any winning chances you get
between f6 check and after King g8
simply Bishop simply b3 and now you
cannot capture because of Bishop c4
check and now you're just lost after
this this will be checkmate so on the
other hand after this b3 move you would
have to play Queen f7 and after Bishop
to c4 now you will have to capture the
bishop rook captures now Queen captures
King captures and now B captures on c4
and it's actually Geary now who is up a
pawn so here after Queen captures on d6
cross and decided to give up the this
pawn and play Queen to f8 so here Gary
decided to play Queen captures on e5 and
it was in this position that the players
agreed to a draw Carson will be a little
bit better but there are no there are no
hopes of anything more than the draw
here due to the wide open position of
the black King and the light square
bishop will always be dangerous along
this dag and also here it was in this
position that they agreed to a draw
after Queen to g7 then this pawn falls
and it will no longer be able to use to
support to the bishop on this diagonal
so here white nor black will be able to
achieve nothing more than a draw and
also a draw is perfectly fine for Carson
and he doesn't feel like pushing for for
anything more here so we did not see
cross and pull a selector here Magnus
Carlsen does win the 2019 Tata Steel
chess tournament with a clear advantage
but as we will show at least another
game from the round 13 of the 2019 Tata
Steel chess tournament we are then going
to show the all of the standings and to
talk a bit more about the entire event
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Paul staples
Kimberley general phrase Ramudu
Robin toy and Nitish
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too in my
previous video so your thing call for
watching and have an excellent rest of
your Sunday thank you all and I'll see
you soon